[Música]
el pasado mes de noviembre debutó un
programa que desde entonces ha sido
considerado como un paso muy importante
para el avance de la Inteligencia
artificial estamos hablando del chat gpt
básicamente se trata de un robot virtual
que responde a todo tipo de preguntas
puede realizar tareas por escrito y
también conversar con fluidez las tareas
las puede hacer en unos 100 idiomas
Aunque su rendimiento varía dependiendo
del idioma funciona mucho mejor en
idioma inglés a pesar de los errores en
la capacidad del programa y el potencial
es enorme y a futuro tiende a mejorar
tal cual así lo han dicho sus creadores
pero su creación genera tanto admiración
como temor y muchos lo consideran una
verdadera amenaza por ser una imitación
muy convincente de la forma de hablar de
los humanos en esencia lo que antes era
una persona expresándose Ahora puede ser
un ro que habla y que Argumenta de
manera artificial pero para quién puede
resultar una amenaza tal vez puede ser
para la hegemonía de Google como
facilitador de información a través de
internet casi todo el mundo utiliza
Google para consultar todo tipo de cosas
en ese sentido también puede ser una
amenaza para la creatividad y para el
aprendizaje de las personas de hecho en
el sector educativo es donde más
críticas ha recibido de hecho ya fue
prohibido en el Nueva York para su uso
entre los estudiantes o por lo menos
entre la comunidad de estudiantes de ese
estado de la Unión Americana veremos
entonces en detalles las bondades del
chat gpt pero porque es una amenaza para
ciertos sectores Qué beneficios puede
traer para el desarrollo de la
Inteligencia artificial Cuál es su
potencial lo vamos a analizar entonces
aquí en el debate de France 24 y para
hablar sobre este tema hemos invitado a
Ana Paula rumoaldo ella es directora del
área de tecnologías digitales de hogan
lobels en México y también está con
nosotros y doia Salazar ella es
fundadora y presidenta del observatorio
de impacto social y ético de
Inteligencia artificial nuestros
televidentes también les recuerdo que
hace parte de esta conversación de este
debate pueden dejar sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales estamos en Twitter en Facebook
también en instagram nos encuentran como
arroba
franz24_es antilogo mi cuenta personal y
la etiqueta es numeral el debate f-24 no
olviden también que todos los contenidos
del programa están disponibles en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Ana Paula Gracias por estar con
nosotros hoy en el programa Ana Paula y
la primera pregunta cuáles son sus
impresiones sobre este avance
tecnológico y todo este revuelo que ha
traído en el mundo de la tecnología del
chat gpt bienvenida qué tal Santiago
Muchas gracias por la invitación es un
gusto y un saludo a la audiencia también
Bueno pues este esta tecnología se ha
puesto de súper moda desde que se lanzó
el chat chipití pero pues si es
necesario decir que no es no es no es
una tecnología completamente nueva esto
es por llamarlo de alguna manera un Spin
off del del chat gptry que este fue
lanzado ya en 2020 entonces
Claro que está o sea ha sido un gran
avance a partir de gpt Tree pero es que
parece por lo que veo que se está viendo
como si fuera algo que no tuviera ningún
antecedente hecho por la misma empresa
porque estas tecnologías son
desarrolladas por Open ahora hay un hay
un cúmulo de de cosas que yo creo que
ese mal entienden a veces alrededor de
lo que de la capacidad de gpi Aunque es
un paso
gigante en términos de cómo ha avanzado
los lelems que son large lands models
que es lo que
específicamente el tipo de Inteligencia
artificial que es gpt tampoco es
esto este asunto que gira mucho como en
noticias de clickbait de que ahora sí ya
hay algo que nos sustituye como
inteligencia humana o que algo que puede
competir con nuestra inteligencia porque
Bueno un un modelo de lenguaje como
estos lo que lo que es en el fondo es un
modelo probabilístico para generar estas
respuestas en en texto entonces no es
que sea que haya entendimiento o que
haya conciencia yo creo que eso es una
de las partes que son realmente
importantes al lo que no es no es este
skynet
no no estamos en esa parte pues entonces
es probabilístico de hecho lo la crítica
que todavía puede existir ahí es el
cuarto chino de ser que desde que sacó
su teoría
será al respecto es que si existe algo
que puede entender sin que haya
realmente que Perdón que pueda generar
una respuesta sin que haya un
entendimiento es como si un mono
estuviera dentro de un cuarto
entendí aprendiendo o dando respuestas
en chino pero no es que entienda chino
sino que sabe o o aprendió más bien la
forma en la que debe responder
la que un programa hace las relaciones
entre los diferentes signos ahora Claro
que
a pesar del del tema de cómo están que
parece que esto no está regulado nunca
no cuando sale esto decimos no pues no
nada que lo regule Dónde está
regulación hay términos y condiciones y
hay una política de contenido que
específicamente aplica a estos temas
entonces en los términos y condiciones
dice para qué no debe de ser utilizado
temas de privacidad temas de seguridad
temas de qué uso es el uso responsable
que le debes dar
y si violas esos términos y condiciones
se puede
finalizar el uso que estés dando de este
de esta herramienta
Ana Paula se me está adelantando mucho
con los temas que vamos a ir analizando
a lo largo del programa continuó con
usted porque estamos teniendo un
problema técnico con la conexión de
nuestra otra invitada mientras retomamos
la conexión yo le pregunto Entonces si
esto es algo que ya existía en
antecedentes y ya existían algunas
tecnologías similares Porque tanto
revuelo a partir de noviembre cuando fue
presentado al público y porque hay tanto
temor al respecto primero porque tanto
revuelo si es algo que ya hemos visto
antes
hay tanto revuelo porque se lanzó el
chat que es de uso para todo el público
Entonces ya nos podemos meter tú y yo
para decir y justo aparte se lanzó en
noviembre Entonces ya podíamos ponerle
Hazme mis mensajes de navidad para para
mi familia para para mis compañeros de
trabajo Los de año nuevo o sea se lanzó
justo en un momento en el que se el
público ya lo podía usar de forma masiva
no se podía utilizar de esa misma forma
y también pues el tema que como lo
comentaste en la presentación que lo que
lo mencionaste muy atinadamente es que
se prohibieron ciertos usos porque la
gente lo empezó a utilizar los
estudiantes por ejemplo para dar ese
para presentar sus tareas incluso fue
prohibido también en un sitio que se
llama stack over Flow que es para para
desarrolladores donde no se podían poner
ahí
respuestas que daba el chat gpt porque
para tirar código no siempre daba
respuestas correctas parece que eran
correctas Pero eso lo que estaba dando
era que se estaban diseminando
respuestas incorrectas entonces creo que
por eso es que ha tenido mucho más
revuelo por Ana Paula y le pregunto esto
En qué fase de la parte de investigación
está está en una parte en una fase
todavía de pruebas donde el usuario como
lo puede utilizar pero pero qué tanto le
falta entonces para su desarrollo para
llegar a ser un producto completamente
disponible que esté completamente listo
para funcionar
Pues mira esa es como la pregunta del
millón porque sería como cuando esté
completa o sea completamente disponible
ya está pero y para uso generalizado Ya
está no está disponible en todos los
países todavía pero
si tu pregunta es más bien como En qué
en qué punto va a alcanzar algún tema de
de que tenga cero errores o algo así
pues no Y eso lo explican no no no no no
estoy segura de que llegue ese punto y
eso lo explican en el momento en el que
si te metes a utilizar el chat que
insisto te puede meter cualquier a
utilizarlo te dicen esto puede tener
instrucciones que puedan causar algún
tipo de daño o puede tener algún tipo de
sesgo porque está por los sets de datos
con los que está alimentado pues
obviamente puede en algún momento
generar respuestas que estén sesgadas
como los mismos sets de datos
sí Entiendo entiendo ese ese punto Por
qué representa esto un importante avance
para la Inteligencia artificial para los
que somos completamente ignorantes en
este tema Ana Paula y no entendemos
mucho de de esta tecnología cuéntenos
porque esto es importante dentro del
segmento de la Inteligencia artificial
Ale te platicaba Santi que una de la de
los avances que representa este tipo de
tecnología es que puede hacer una cosa
que se llama multitasking que la
conocemos esa palabra la conocemos algo
que se puede que entre humanos significa
que puedes hacer varias cosas a la vez y
trasladado al tema específicamente de
Inteligencia artificial significa que
puede hacer más de una cosa Generalmente
y esto creo que sí lo puede entender la
audiencia que no sepa nada acerca del
tema que seguramente escucharon las
notas de talan diligencia artificial
ahora es experta jugando ajedrez experta
jugando Go experta jugando lo que sea
pero era experta en una cosa y esa era
la crítica también en muchas ocasiones
de académicos y al respecto hace bien
una cosa entonces que haga multitasking
es que puede hacer más de una cosa y qué
hace genera guiones novelas poesía tira
código lo que o sea hace te puede hacer
cartas agradecer un montón de cosas
diferentes entonces no es una
Inteligencia artificial que solo sepa
hacer un tipo de tarea digamos que solo
haga guiones o que solo haga novelas o
que solo haga tareas sino que pueda ser
diferentes cosas Pero todas son
relacionadas con el lenguaje porque
recordemos que es un modelo de lenguaje
entonces
esa es uno de sus de sus mayores avances
no sé si más o menos eso responda a tu
pregunta en términos generales Claro que
sí Ana Paula queda muy claro eso Y eso
me lleva a preguntarle Entonces cómo
esto es multitasking puede desempeñar
diferentes tareas esto lo podemos usar
en todo tipo de actividades o esto tiene
todavía un segmento muy determinado es
muy académico o es muy que se sabe al
respecto nombre no es para nada muy
académico es algo que se puede utilizar
y justo ese es el tema de su gran
popularidad que platicábamos que se
puede utilizar para hacer tareas se
puede utilizar para generar artículos de
hecho gpt free saltó a mucho a bueno
tuvo mucha fama cuando se empezaron a
generar artículos a partir de su uso que
supuestamente eran Bueno sí resultaban
no eran distinguibles de lo que podía
escribir un humano a lo que estaba
generado Digamos como contenido
sintético llamémosle Entonces eso es es
el tema
Ana Paula continuo con usted porque
seguimos teniendo problemas técnicos
para continuar la comunicación con
nuestra otra invitada entonces seguimos
conversando hasta que podamos incorporar
al debate a nuestra otra invitada
paso entonces a preguntarle por una de
las grandes críticas que has recibido el
chat gpt y es que puede generar
justamente una ruptura en cuanto a la
creatividad al aprendizaje en todo esto
en el marco de la educación sobre todo
usted lo mencionaba hay unos textos que
uno no sabe Cuáles han hecho por
contenido
sintético o hecho por una persona por su
creatividad y por su capacidad de
lenguaje es en serio esta amenaza de la
creatividad esto podría afectarnos a
nosotros a la raza humana a largo plazo
puede puede generar puede generar
ciertos estilos dependiendo de los sets
de datos con los que se ha alimentado
Digamos si yo pongo el estilo de alguna
escritora en específico me puede generar
un resultado que sea en ese estilo y eso
fue lo que un fan hizo con la música de
Nick cave Y entonces Nick dijo sí se
parece a mi estilo Pero esto no tiene
ninguna O sea no ha experimentado lo que
yo experimenté para generar ese tipo de
producto Bueno ese tipo de resultado
pues ahí es donde vamos al tema de la
creatividad ya si lo vemos desde el lado
técnico yo te podría decir que si está
alimentado por diferentes sets de todo
lo que de todo lo que sea de como
quieras que salga el producto como sea
que tú pongas los parámetros para que
salga algo es que eso va a ser un
producto de lo que de lo que se haya de
lo que se haya dado de input o sea de
los sets de datos para que se produzca
ese resultado
estilista estilísticamente o como
resultado en general
Pero va a ser un estilo anterior
Entonces dónde va cómo me va a salir el
siguiente Nick cave o algo más conocido
dónde me va a salir el siguiente guión
de un Guillermo del Toro si yo pongo a
que me salga en guiones tipo Guillermo
del Toro me puede salir uno Cuándo me va
a salir un nuevo Guillermo del Toro que
esa es la pregunta de creatividad
entonces para el tema de creatividad
Considero que puede no ser
necesariamente La amenaza de la que se
habla pero también cuánto contenido hay
que tal vez no es tan profundo o que tal
vez no es completamente un estilo súper
personal y hay mucho contenido que lo
que se necesita para para mantener el
ritmo que se tiene de lectura y de
atención en internet lo que se hace es
producción de contenido uno tras otro de
forma masiva Entonces tal vez para eso
sí pueda servir de de cierta manera y de
lo que te mencionaba de que el artículo
este con el que se hizo también
famoso gpt fue por cierto fue un tema de
autoayuda y hubo también otro en el que
el artículo se le dieron parámetros muy
específicos entonces también depende del
Trump o de la instrucción que se le dé
ya concretamente en el chat gpt para ver
cuál es el resultado que te da a lo que
te llevo con esto es que el aquí tenemos
que o sea sí tiene
su el peso Si si tiene cierto peso el
tipo de instrucción y la calidad de la
instrucción y el detalle que le dé la
persona que está buscando el resultado
concreto
entiendo Ana Paula La invito para que le
demos la bienvenida a esta conversación
a Samir Estefan él es ceo de T etcétera
y también es consultor de transformación
digital él se encuentra en la ciudad de
Bogotá en la capital colombiana Samir
Gracias por atendernos a esta hora aquí
en el debate de France 24 por atender
Nuestra llamada estábamos conversando
con Ana Paula tal vez los puntos más
básicos enterándonos y poniéndonos en
contexto de lo que significa Esto del
chat gpt para los que no sabemos
absolutamente nada de Inteligencia
artificial y quiero comenzar
preguntándole el punto básico de esta
discusión sus impresiones lo que
significa este avance tecnológico que ha
tenido tanto revuelo a nivel
internacional desde que fue presentado
en noviembre
Hola Santiago Hola Ana Paula Hola a
todos Sí yo creo que hay hay varios
temas Ana Paula tocó un parque Me parece
muy importante si es el primero es que
no es magia sí lo que lo que
chachi le puede a uno entregar digamos
que depende también de la calidad de la
pregunta de los parámetros que que
seamos capaces de digamos de
introducirlo hemos visto con otras
herramientas de Inteligencia artificial
por ejemplo como como Meet Journey sí
quienes hoy producen dibujos fantásticos
a través de Nick Johnny han trabajado en
en aprender cómo se le debe pedir y
cuáles son las instrucciones que se le
debe dar al algoritmo Entonces yo creo
que el primero es eso no es magia el
segundo es
este es el futuro así como así como
hemos visto durante años que cada vez
tenemos herramientas tecnológicas que
nos permiten hacer cosas de una manera
mucho más rápida mucho más óptima mucho
más productiva Este es uno de esos que
creo que ha causado el revuelo
Sencillamente porque lo estamos viendo
aplicado digamos a tareas más entre
comillas normales mundanas sí
Inteligencia artificial se utiliza hoy
por ejemplo para detección de cáncer
pero eso es un Nicho muy específico
Inteligencia artificial se utiliza hoy
para eficiencia energética pero es un
Nicho muy específico pero cuando
encontramos un algoritmo como este que
nos puede ayudar a escribir mejor que
nos puede ayudar a crear
discursos presentaciones guiones
etcétera etcétera Pues creo que llama
más la atención y va a ser no solo el
siguiente paso porque chat lo sea sino
porque ya vimos primero que Microsoft
dijo lo voy a incorporar en mis
herramientas de ofimática y lo voy a
incorporar en Bing y segundo porque ya
esta mañana Google anunció Bart que es
como un un modelo muy equivalente un un
modelo de de un algoritmo conversacional
inteligente basado A diferencia de este
en una base de conocimiento más amplia y
internet cosa que en este caso todavía
chachipitino hace Samir Entonces estamos
digamos en el inicio de un capítulo de
hacia donde se mueve la tecnología de la
Inteligencia artificial Porque si vemos
Que Google también está dando una
respuesta que era justamente uno de los
que se estaba viendo digamos en peligro
o amenazado por la aparición de este de
este chat muchos hablaban ya del fin de
la hegemonía de Google en este término
de búsquedas por internet es hacia donde
nos estamos dirigiendo es es hacia donde
el mercado nos va a llevar cómo lo ve
usted
Santiago el 75% de la gente ha usado
Inteligencia artificial y no sabe que ha
usado Inteligencia artificial desde hace
unos ocho años que empezamos de verdad
haber aplicabilidad de muchos de los
modelos de Inteligencia artificial la
gente los ha empezado a usar sin saber
hoy en día este es uno de ellos En donde
efectivamente la gente dice Okay voy a
usar esto pero sí efectivamente vamos a
ver cada vez más implementaciones de
diferentes modelos de Inteligencia
artificial de diferentes modelos de
algoritmos que incorporaremos dentro de
nuestros flujos de trabajo de vida
etcétera etcétera claro lo que pasa es
que aquí estamos conscientes que lo
vamos a utilizar lo que usted dice
muchas veces en nuestra vida diaria
puede que las hayamos utilizado y no lo
sabemos en este momento estaba pensando
yo en donde pude haber utilizado
Inteligencia artificial en mi vida
diaria no se me ocurre ningún escenario
pero aquí en este Tal vez eso también
ayuda un poco más al revuelo porque las
personas sienten que están teniendo
acceso a esta tecnología que
Aparentemente era tecnología muy
avanzada guardada para para cosas
espaciales o para desarrollos médicos y
ahora está pues simplemente la
disponibilidad de la mano pero ya desde
antes la teníamos Ana Paula sigue con
nosotros en México también es parte de
esta conversación Ana Paula quiero
preguntarles por por este tipo de
situaciones que se han empezado a
presentar de restringir el uso de por
ejemplo del chat gpt por ejemplo en el
estado de Nueva York dentro de la
comunidad académica dentro de la
comunidad de los estudiantes de
secundaria porque se les estaba
facilitando mucho las respuestas para
los exámenes las respuestas para las
tareas esto a nivel educativo netamente
puede empezar a generar problemas ya lo
estamos empezando a ver cómo lo analizan
a Paula
Gracias por la pregunta Santiago Bueno
nada más antes de ir con esa pregunta me
gustaría
decirte que tal vez una de las cosas en
las que hayas utilizado Inteligencia
artificial ha sido cuando escuchas el
los descubrimientos semanales o cuando
escuchas Perdón los descubrimientos
semanales de Spotify ahí es Inteligencia
artificial aplicada a haber predice si
conforme con lo que tú has escuchado
esta música te puede gustar es también
un modelo predictivo o sea Ahí lo has
escuchado pero como bien decías pues no
es que lo utilices
para general porque lo que generas con
el otro es un output que por términos y
condiciones te dicen aparte es tuyo
entonces también Eso es parte de todo el
hype bueno y en el tema educativo creo
que podría causar tanto O sea no es una
herramienta que que sea como un una
limitante o una cosa nueva en el tema de
de escuelas en general
Siempre han existido formas de hacer
algún tipo de trampa y aquí también es
que como el como el el texto no se no se
ve tan tan limitado como se podía ver
con otras herramientas anteriores pues
ahí es donde llega el el Pues el riesgo
no de que no se no se distingue pero
ahora la pregunta es si no se distingue
y me gustó mucho esta crítica que por
cierto es de Simon service Decía si si
estamos no le estamos quitando la
máscara algo mágico o a un o algo que
sea perfecto tal vez estamos quitándole
la máscara a que nuestra barra es bien
baja Entonces eso Tal vez se expone que
en el tema educativo tal vez la barra
también era baja y entonces está
pudiendo hacer cierto tipo de tareas
cierto tipo de de papers sean de poder
se pueden hacer que que sean que sean
aceptables Porque tampoco es que el el
contenido sea por sí solo esté
completamente bien hecho y vuelvo al
tema de cómo se le da la instrucción
Entonces
eso es lo que esos son mis
consideraciones al respecto Samir su
impresión sobre este tema
Santiago esto ya lo vivimos con el
computador si ya lo vimos con el
internet esto ya lo vivimos con la
calculadora mire Cómo funcionan hoy en
un colegio o en una universidad los
exámenes de cálculo trigonometría lo
importante no es la respuesta porque la
respuesta la puede sacar el estudiante o
de una calculadora gráfica o lo puede
sacar de internet Lo importante es el
proceso y creo y ahí coincido con Ana
Paula en un tema y es de pronto no es
que la vara esté baja De pronto es que
estamos viviendo con la vara que no es
sí Entonces tenemos que entender que
estas herramientas van a ser parte de
las herramientas laborales con las
cuales van a trabajar las personas yo he
puesto en un par de artículos que
escritos etcétera El ejemplo de cuando
aparecieron los primeros computadores
capaces de manejar gráficas hubo muchas
facultades de arquitectura que se
negaron a utilizar aplicaciones de tipo
Cat Sí hoy en día un arquitecto que no
sabe utilizar aplicaciones de tipo Cat
no es un arquitecto empleable sí lo
mismo va a pasar con esto lo importante
es entender cómo hacemos para medir
realmente el conocimiento de los
estudiantes sí y que el y que la
medición que yo esté haciendo no sea
digamos susceptible hacer esta trampa
pero Incluso en ese caso la compañía
Open anunció que está sacando
básicamente un servicio con el que
cualquier profesor puede entrar y
validar si ese texto fue construido a
partir de un algoritmo de Inteligencia
artificial pero sí creo y coincido con
Ana Paula uno tenemos que cambiar la
barra no solo de altura Sí si nos
tenemos que cambiar la barra de cómo lo
medimos Y de nuevo ya lo hicimos por
ejemplo con cuando como como digamos la
manera en como
miramos y medimos el conocimiento de
quienes toman materias como cálculo
matemáticas trigonometría no no
basándonos solo en el resultado final
sino poniéndolos a mostrar el proceso
para validar que efectivamente si
aprendieron lo que tenían que aprender
no importa el resultado la operación lo
que importa es el proceso con el que se
logró llegar a ese resultado es esto
otra vez otro episodio en el que vuelve
a quedar sobre la mesa este debate sobre
si este tipo de tecnologías de la
Inteligencia artificial debe de tener un
marco legal unas leyes que regulen este
tipo de usos la pregunta para los dos
hago la ronda entonces a la inversa Ana
Paula su opinión ya usted Nos daba unas
unas cuantas luces al inicio del
programa sobre esta parte legal Pero
esto debe tener unas cláusulas un marco
que encierra un poco la actividad
Gracias por la pregunta Santiago pues
una de las de los temas justo que están
candentes ahorita son las propuestas de
regulación en materia de Inteligencia
artificial en México no tenemos una
propuesta pero sí que la hay en Europa y
en Estados Unidos estas propuestas están
más encaminadas al tema de Cómo se
utilizan los datos personales y
específicamente los datos personales
sensibles en los modelos predictivos y
que tanto pueden generar algún resultado
de discriminación Entonces en este caso
ahorita ya si me preguntas de ahorita
qué tenemos con el chatti
autorregulación con sus términos y
condiciones y la sección que tiene
también de confidencialidad y datos
personales que si estás algún tienes
algún tema ahí de datos personales Pues
tienes que generar una cosa que se llama
Data procesing adendum o una denda de de
tratamiento de datos personales para que
no exista ahí ningún tema porque es lo
que de lo que le impacta al chatti es lo
que está actualmente Sí regulado en
específico que datos personales creo que
eventualmente
sí dado el uso que se le está dando cada
vez para las personas masivo de estas
herramientas de Inteligencia artificial
sí puede ser que se necesite algún tipo
de regulación pero yo no Aunque sea
abogada no soy del equipo que piensa que
si no hay regulación no hay nada yo más
bien pienso que se tiene que estudiar
bien cómo es que se requiere una
regulación que Cuáles son los detalles
que requiere una regulación y no caer en
el error de que simplemente aventarnos a
hacerla Porque algo está utilizado
masivamente y puede representar un
llamémosle o que se le llame peligro
porque si hay algo peor que no tener una
regulación no tener una regulación en un
tema en el que se mencione que se
necesita regulación es tener una mala
ley Eso sí puede ser peor
su opinión sobre el marco legal
necesario o no
y yo creo pero yo creo que más que un
marco legal necesitamos un marco ético
y ahí Tenemos un gran problema y es que
definir éticamente lo que puede o no
puede hacer o la respuesta que debería
tener un algoritmo de Inteligencia
artificial depende mucho de la cultura
en donde estamos hay un ejercicio bien
interesante que se hizo algo usted
Algunos años se había hecho hace muchos
años con un tranvía pero lo convirtieron
a un vehículo autónomo que que tiene que
tomar una decisión sale de una curva y
el vehículo tiene que tomar una decisión
dice atropella una persona mayor de edad
que está en la mitad de la calle o vira
y atropella a tres jóvenes que están
sentados y depende de la cultura en
donde usted hace esa pregunta La
respuesta es diametralmente diferente
para Los japoneses hay que proteger la
vida del adulto mayor para los
norteamericanos hay que proteger la vida
de los jóvenes sí Entonces el reto que
tenemos es cómo logramos una
homogenización real de un marco legal de
hasta donde debería la Inteligencia
artificial utilizarse y deberían quienes
están expuestos a ellos estar informados
de eso pero detrás de eso hay un debate
mucho más grande y es ese marco ético
sobre el cual deberíamos hacer el
desarrollo y el la programación de esos
algoritmos y digamos en ese caso del
vehículo quien es responsable es
responsable el dueño del vehículo es
responsable quien desarrolló el software
es responsable la fábrica lo que lo que
lo fabricó ahí tenemos un hueco
muchísimo más grande que el legal pero
coincido no podemos dejar todo al libre
albedrío creo que necesitamos por lo
menos unos marcos que por ahora Europa
pareciera ser el que está liderando en
tratar de crear algo bajo bajo los
cuales todo el mundo se pueda guiar en
ese orden de ideas Samir entonces la
parte ética Cómo utilizar esto de la
mejor manera cómo cómo instaurar esa
parte ética Cómo combatir la
desinformación Y cómo poner ciertos
límites porque esto no es infinito
tampoco entonces
esa parte Cómo se puede llegar a
construir
Sí yo creo que ahí yo creo que hay
varios temas ahí que son importantes el
primero es de quien lo desarrolla cierto
el segundo es de que lo usa y ahorita
María Paula hablaba de autorregulación
yo creo que tenemos que estar preparados
para enseñarle a nuestros hijos Cuál es
el efecto real de utilizar este tipo de
herramientas cierto para que ellos
puedan tomar una decisión informada
listo creo que todas las personas que
hoy están jugando con el algoritmo súper
chévere tienen que entender qué pasa con
sus datos entonces
Lamentablemente América Latina no Mejor
dicho no vamos a ver llegar una
legislación por lo menos lógica antes de
dos o tres años todavía en la mayoría de
los países de América Latina estamos
discutiendo el tema de Uber Sí y Esto
fue hace ocho años entonces Imagínese
cuándo vamos a empezar a hablar de este
tema entonces creo que tenemos que
arrancar por los colegios por las
universidades por los papás nosotros
como usuarios a tratar de entender de
una manera autogestionada y
autorregulada
hacemos el mejor uso de las herramientas
y entender Cuáles son los riesgos de
ellas Bueno hay países en donde el tema
por ejemplo de la plataforma Como por
ejemplo Uber o plataformas de hospedaje
no está ni siquiera siendo debatido y no
tiene ningún tipo de Marco en este
momento y no hay interés de las
autoridades de establecer nada al
respecto Ana Paula su impresión sobre
este este marco entonces de lo ético
Cómo construirlo Cómo ponerle cierto
límite y también esa lucha contra la
desinformación se vuelve desde mi punto
de vista otro punto
importante
apto para este tipo de de problemáticas
que ya no solamente es particular de los
medios de comunicación ya lo vemos en
diferentes áreas
hay temas o temazo Santiago Pero antes
de eso quiero irme nada más a algo que
mencionó Samir que me pareció muy
interesante donde decía que en la región
podíamos tener un desarrollo de La
regulación en aproximadamente dos tres
años Me encantaría que fuera así que
surgiera una que se creara se tejiera
una buena regulación en ese periodo me
parece un periodo sumamente optimista
que tenemos creemos en la región que se
puede hacer algo en ese periodo pero en
realidad no lo sé yo le echaría mínimo
unos cinco años ahora en el tema de
ética también Creo que bueno aunque está
el tema de autorregulación y los límites
éticos para qué se puede utilizar
te lo pongo con algo bien concreto
términos y condiciones y por y
condiciones de de contenido del chatti
lo que dicen es cuando tú generes algo
es es tuyo pero o sea sí es que te
recomendamos y esos son los términos y
condiciones de opening que digas que se
generaron con una herramienta no con
esta herramienta entonces Y tenemos una
violación a eso cuando no se da esta
autoría Entonces tampoco es que se
cumplan estos términos y condiciones ni
las políticas que se establecen respecto
del contenido eso también nos hace
preguntarnos a la vez que tanto sirve La
regulación actual como la tenemos de los
términos y condiciones que tanto sirve
que tengas todas las políticas a textos
seguido blanco y negro y quién las Lee Y
entonces también cómo incentivamos el
uso ético
si lo vamos a dejar así dejando toda la
carga sobre el usuario Pues es que no la
leíste Pues es que aquí dice claro los
usos correctos para que el usuario se
quede preguntándose de qué se trata esto
como cuando lees un aviso de privacidad
Y dices de qué se trató Entonces yo creo
que también se tiene que incentivar ese
ese uso ético claro me echan de un par
de minutos para finalizar el programa
Ana Paula Samir quiero que hagamos las
conclusiones de lo que sigue entonces
para esta área de la Inteligencia
artificial de lo que nos viene en los
próximos meses en el marco porque ya si
Google tiene una respuesta más o menos
rápida es porque esto se está volviendo
una competencia entre estas compañías de
tecnología comienzo entonces con Ana
Paula para hacer la ronda la inversa su
conclusión de lo que nos deja esto el
chat gpt
yo creo que mi conclusión al respecto es
que entendamos Que aunque tiene la
comunidad embelesada con el tipo de
respuestas que que puede que es capaz de
producir y la rapidez entendamos que
esto no no es magia no es magia esto es
ingeniería en esa Esa es mi conclusión
y que se perdone y que sea una
herramienta que podamos integrar a a
nuestra vida también como lo mencionabas
a Miriam eso estoy Completamente de
acuerdo que entendamos Cuál es el
potencial de la herramienta y cómo se
puede utilizar que si no la aprendemos a
utilizar y nada más pensamos que es algo
para para poder hacer trampa y
facilitarnos las actividades
del día a día para eso es y me pareció
excelente la metáfora que mencionó Sami
respecto del uso de la computadora el
uso de la calculadora es como en general
esta tecnología en específico el de
Inteligencia artificial es lo que es la
Inteligencia artificial en general Es
una herramienta para potencializar la
capacidad humana no una cosa que
sustituye a la inteligencia humana eso
hay que tenerlo muy claro primero está
la inteligencia humana y y Ese temor
Creo que ya es infundido que este tipo
de avances pueda reemplazar en cierta
forma
nuestra mente nuestro cerebro y a
nuestra capacidad creativa Samir su
conclusión para el cierre del programa
en algún momento Será posible que la
Inteligencia artificial reemplace Muchos
trabajos lo que sí va a pasar en los
próximos 10 es que alguien que sabe
utilizar este tipo de algoritmos va a
reemplazar los trabajos de aquellos que
no lo saben hacer así como pasó con
tantas otras herramientas entonces creo
que es nuestro deber informarnos
aprender incorporarlos Ojalá más
profesores en vez de prohibirlos los
incorporen dentro de su proceso digamos
de aprendizaje educativo creativo porque
creo que ahí vamos a ver un resultado
bien bien interesante Ana Paula Samir un
gusto conversar con ustedes sobre este
tema personalmente me han aclarado
muchas dudas creo que el más ignorante
de todos frente a este tema era yo antes
que muchos de las personas que nos están
viendo Gracias por habernos explicado en
detalle y en palabras muy simples todo
este tema yo les agradezco a ustedes
también por la sintonía En nombre del
equipo técnico Les agradecemos haber
estado con nosotros hoy la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y la producción de invitados a
cargo de Tania Herrera Pueden seguir
dejando todos sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
sigan con France 24
[Música]